I...
dreamed about you once,
before I even knew
you existed.
Dreams are powerful omens.
Perhaps we were
meant to find each other.
Ciri really changes Yennefer.
We see that, definitely at
the end of this Season.
It is that moment of like,
ah this is Yennefer
because she spent the
entire season
with sort of hearing
bits and bobs,
through Geralt
and clearly, you know,
she's a smart girl,
she knows that...
she can sense she means
a lot to Geralt...
Who is Yennefer?
and I think she's just excited
to find out more about her,
and how they know
each other and everything.
Obviously she’s given a huge clue
when she steps into that scene,
as to what their relationship is...
Geralt, do you know what
to do with this…
sorry.
Ciri.
And you know we’ve all been in
that kind of position
you know where you’re kind
of like, sorry, oh my god,
I’m so sorry, I’m gonna
leave now.
Sorry…
You definitely have those
embarrassing moments,
where you’re like oh my god
Dad is kissing someone!
Immediately in the
conversation where they're
you know, surrounded by
the food and everything,
in Melitele,
I think Ciri's just taking in
the fact that she’s like,
clearly in front of another
very strong woman
who she admires.
Anyone who’s any strong female
is a reminder of her grandmother,
and she always looked up to
the strength of her grandmother.
I think she obviously sees that
in Yennefer instantly.
Geralt says you’re the most
powerful mage he's ever known.
Well that's nice of him.
Ciri holds up a mirror to Yennefer
like no other character could,
because she's got this
enormous amount of power
which she can't control,
and that takes Yennefer right back
to when she was 14 years old,
and Tissaia was teaching
her how to kind of
hone this chaos.
It is your job to control chaos,
not become it.
I can.
Yennefer sees in Ciri,
kind of, Yennefer
as a child in Ciri,
and Ciri's struggles with trying to
understand her magic,
and what's inside her,
and her identitiy, I suppose.
As an orphan, like Yennefer,
she can relate to that,
and because of that, she's
of great use to Ciri.
Without, I think,
the relationship
between Tissaia
and Yennefer,
you wouldn't get the possibility
with Yennefer and Ciri.
Yennefer meets Ciri and realises
she can be the same thing
to Ciri.
Use your knowledge of
magic to train the girl.
You're the only person who's
helped to control her powers.
When you have power like this
never apologise.
One of her main issues
has been trusting
I don't trust you.
Especially after everything she's
experienced in Season 1,
in regards to just meeting,
encountering, people on this continent
and how they
can be so brutal.
I said stop.
Our name is not Mousesack.
But on top of that,
she’s also still this Season
uncovering things about her family
and her background that she never knew,
so she’s constantly got this
idea of lying and lack of trust,
and so I think it’s a big blow
when Yennefer does that,
it’s like another example of why
I can’t trust anyone except
Geralt at this point, you know?
I had no choice.
My chaos… I thought I had to…
I think for Yennefer, the overriding
kind of emotion
she goes to find Ciri with is just
I need to get my powers back
and she’s never kind of
hesitated before now
to get what she wants.
And then when she’s with Ciri,
she just wants to save her.
Trust your power to do the work.
She realizes at the end of Season 2,
that she’s willing to sacrifice herself
to become a mother to Ciri.
The relationship she forms with Ciri
in the time that she’s taking her
on her journey to Voleth Meir -
Ciri just changes Yennefer’s
perspective on everything.
I think the way that
Season 2 ended,
obviously they did still create a bond.
There’s this moment we established
where Geralt comes to them
in that scene,
sort of implicates he has to kill a monster
and we played with the idea that she’s
wondering is he going to kill Yennefer.
Where are you going?
To slay a monster.
Whatever Yennefer may have done,
she doesn’t want her to be killed.
Say it.
So there still is that connection
and it’s strong enough
to maintain some kind of
like care for her in a way,
but it’s still going to be something
that needs to be worked through I believe.
I’m intrigued to see how we
confront that in Season 3.
Us three, we’ll help each other.
What is destined cannot be avoided.